The Joe Rogan experience do look and man,
man,
I think it's a weapon now.
You know a global car right here.
If I throw a hook from my right here right now suck,
right?
It's all calcified,
Yeah.
So,
um,
where are you at right now in terms of like,
when does the UFC usually come to you with a,
an idea of what,
who are you gonna fight next time?
Obviously you beat Latifa.
He was top five.
Yeah.
So you're three and five.
What do they,
what do they got you ranked now eighth or ninth.
How's that work?
Do you tell?
How the fuck am I asking him?
How does,
how does Koreans are not in the top five?
I beat the number three and the five.
When I was three,
they put me at six.
I don't know,
they put me at six like I'll beat Glover and I went to six.
By the time I fought,
I was 10 that night in Cali.
I was ranked 10 thing.
And how,
how's that happen?
Then I'd be the leader who was six and I went,
or fifth or fourth one.
He was,
I went to six and then a week later I was at seven.
The next day he came out of the eight like,
which is like this.
This makes no sense and that's why there's no fights.
Yeah,
they don't even care what you clearly top 10 you know,
whatever number that is.
I mean it's a,
you got a murderer's row,
people in that division,
you know,
so they,
when,
when do you think they'll come to you with an offer from the was they wanted me
to fight Gus at a time.
Like I said,
after found the microphone.
I don't want to fight anything else until my babies here.
When the baby's here and everything's checked out,
I don't have to be in camp is stress this and this.
Once that's all done,
we can talk.
And they called me a couple weeks later about Gus because he tweeted me and had
them ask me area and I said the same thing.
Like I'm waiting til my baby's Jen.
That was March 15th the due date of my baby was March 12th but it's too close.
Not risking it,
you know?
Then it's like,
all right,
what about June 1st and I was just saying,
let me,
can I finish with my baby and stuff?
I'm not really even training my home with my wife.
I'm doing a little bit here and there,
but I'm worried about her now.
She's been with me ride down his whole time.
That was my time to focus on her,
what she needed.
She didn't want me to wait,
so I'm here and they kept calling.
I kept calling.
I just kept saying,
no,
no.
And they kept asking me and I'm like,
hi.
And Allie,
it was like,
I mean,
what if we get more money if they give him my wife's like,
if we can get more or take it back.
If they give you more,
I'll let you go.
But yeah,
we can start camp or whatever because I had to give him more.
We do it and they say,
oh no,
you're not doing nothing.
I wouldn't wait,
let me finish this.
Literally my baby came out and I felt that,
I asked the doctors everything fine.
They did the test,
everything came back could like,
there's no problems.
And he had to go to the doctors.
Nothing.
She's like,
you're fine.
You got a healthy baby boy.
Congratulations.
Literally pick my phone up.
Tweeted Gus.
Gus,
you still want to go June 1st you want to do it?
I'm your huckleberry.
Let's go London.
I'll come.
Yes.
Court.
You know I wanted to fight.
Let's do it.
Ali called me.
It's on.
His managers called me.
We want to fight.
Let's do it.
June 1st same,
same pay.
No race on nothing.
Whatever I was getting,
let's go.
Takes Dana.
They literally,
they called me the day before on my way to the hospital.
I get a cough,
my lead,
they want to,
if you want to fight,
Bro,
I'm going away.
I call you after we figure it out.
I say yes.
Less than 24 hours later.
They say no.
We gave him to Anthony Smith.
Now the fuck y'all call me for yesterday,
harassing me all his camp.
Now I say yes and you're taking it away like why y'all?
What's going on and that.
That made me mad.
Then they call me for Luke Rockhold like I'm not,
no,
not taking a step back.
Like I want you to be here for the title.
I'll be Luke.
What are going to say?
Cause I guess if they told Ali,
if I beat Glover since he was gonna fight a leader,
that premium contingent for title fight,
they gave me a new contract and everything with all that in it signed it.
Then as I go,
he need one more fight and there's a guy make him an a fight and Ali's and no,
cause he managed both of those.
Don't you think that Luke Rockhold is a good fight for you?
But it wouldn't do not find it,
but it would definitely elevate you in the public side,
the guy you don't think it would help you
rank is what?
No,
you would think Galit or the chief would have helped me in the rankings and go
over,
I don't buy that because I think they'd like rankings.
Like even if it's not one,
one through ten eight any one of those guys could fight for the title if they
get look,
Tiago like Tiago Santos.
Right.
I mean you lost David Branch,
what a year ago.
Right at a middle.
Same that I beat up Pat Cummings.
Yeah.
With 20th or April 13th or 18th,
whatever.
Now he's fighting for the title.
I mean it was a quick ascension from,
you know,
devastating knockouts and fighting like a wild maniac like he does and he's a
wild fighter to watch.
Very,
very entertaining guy and that's all it took.
But who was in that?
He didn't have to be the big name guy.
That's thing he be young.
Black.
What you I killed on my fourth fight in UFC beat Jimmy the chimney.
Manoa.
Um,
stopped him there.
Anders and the other guy,
we're both 85 hours.
She didn't,
so he had two fights is because he had knockoff that thing.
Like I said,
I told him,
I was like,
Bro,
it's a good fight.
He's the same thing you said.
It's a good fight.
Like Ali,
let's look at who I fought.
I'll beat Glover who was third.
They still didn't put me in top flight.
I'll be a little TV.
What he says next to beat the champ,
whatever.
When I beat him,
they still don't give me the credibility.
It's like,
oh he's washed up now and I as I pop her Twitter I like,
I apologize to anybody I'd beat because once you lose to me it's Kinda like
you're a nobody.
I'm like I'm sorry for that time.
All their posts a thing of the day saying oh these guys all feel they get six
months.
I fell for the same thing I get two years.
I said I'm sorry times cause you lost to me.
I think that says
you get the short end of the stick.
I'm sorry.
It's just though the same thing is half of that asshole coach when you're in
college is it is in the same way and that's why your motivation back to tweets
and shit cause in my head things like that that I've been through,
you know I should learn but now it doesn't matter.
But in my mind,
I've voiced my opinion set coach and when I proved her wrong,
I ran into his assistant coach later on in life and he said he's,
he doesn't really like you anymore cause the guy actually I fall in the ultimate
fighter was his best friend,
Kelly and us,
one of his all Americans.
He used to call him back when I was in college trying to discipline me if I like
do some shit to piss him off,
he would have Kelly come in and try to beat me up.
Never happened.
Like I've,
he couldn't beat me up like that.
He used to get pissed at that.
So the fact that he thought he had like a hold on me with this transcript and I
got out and then I ended up fighting Kelly on the show and he said that two and
pregnant talking,
he'd kill you in MMA,
he could kill you and MMA when the opportunity came and I beat him and that
somebody telling me like he wasn't happy about that.
He didn't like the fact that you beat Kelly.
Like,
I'm sorry,
I don't do things that,
this thing where you don't feel like you get in the respect that you deserve.
It does motivate you though.
It does give you like a little bit of extra juice in the gym.
I mean,
I'm a motivated guy anyway.
Highly motivated.
I wake up,
my open my eyes,
it sounds to get to work.
So you son's born the Anthony Smith common.
He had a,
you know,
Anthony Smith survived against Jon Jones and you know,
especially early on he looked good,
you know,
showed good technique,
showed that he's,
he's really a world class fighter.
And I think that they just think that that would be,
he probably said yes when you said no,
and they gave it to them,
you know,
while you were waiting and your son was being born.
So now you're just waiting for another call.
But the thing is like,
go back to that real fast.
Say he say yes and he said,
no,
I watched this interview.
Excuse me,
what area?
Hawaii.
And they said the day after he followed Jon Jones,
they caught him about Anthony Summit or about,
uh,
Gus.
Right.
So that was why I'm saying,
I know I was calling me.
So it's Kinda like they were just throwing it out there and Holly said,
uh,
I guess they offered it to Johnnie Walker.
Johnnie Walker's manager made a post.
I seen it offered us Gus,
like they were just throwing out there for whoever's gonna be the first person
to say yes.
Well,
they probably have a bunch of people say yes.
And then they sit down and they go over it.
Like,
what looks best for us?
what do we have.